Humans dream about needing us and traveling through the galaxy,
but we were born too early to be part of it or where are we?
The reality is we could begin our dream by building a moon base.
Today.
We actually do have the technology and current estimates from NASA and the
private sector say it could be done for 20 to $40 billion spread out over about
a decade.
The price is comparable to the international space station or the budget surplus
of Germany in 2017 not that big an investment.
Really the payoff would be a measurable.
The moon is a sandbox to develop new technologies and exploit unlimited
resources.
It would start a new space race and lay the foundation for us to spread out into
the solar system and beyond.
It would create a vast array of new technologies to benefit us on earth and we
would all be part of it.
So why are we doing as well?
Sadly,
it's hard to get governments interested in longterm investments in the future of
humanity.
Let's imagine just doing it.
If we start today,
how would we build a moon base
throughout history?
Colonization happened in phases in the first phase of the age of exploration of
the new world.
For example,
European monarchs funded expeditions to chart and discover and to stake their
claims.
They planted a flag and set up a camp,
but they didn't stay in the second phase.
Small missions set up outposts and settlements are founded,
which was still very dependent on their home countries for supplies,
some failed,
but others survived and established a permanent presence only then in the third
phase did a true colony form to which tradesmen and laborers could emigrate,
creating new wealth and opportunities for themselves and their families,
sending extreme wealth back to their countries of origin.
When we colonize the moon,
we'll go through the same three phases this time without murdering millions of
innocent people in the process.
The moon is not a welcoming place for living things.
A Moon Day lasts 29 earth days with a difference of navy 300 degrees Celsius
between sunlight and shade.
There's no atmosphere to shield us from meteorites,
big and small or cosmic radiation.
We're still,
the lunar surface is covered in a layer of nasty Jagat dust.
The moon is hard,
but we're good at doing hard things.
In the first phase of Luna colonization,
our explorer has proved it can be done,
that a new world can be reached.
This phase started 60 years ago with the Apollo missions.
Since then,
satellites like the American lunar reconnaissance orbiter have mapped the moon.
While rivers,
like the Chinese Youtube,
have studied the composition of the lunar surface looking for water,
ice,
and metals.
Phase one is more or less complete.
We know what we need to know to enter phase two in the second phase.
Astronauts,
we'll build the first moon base and this could begin today.
The first small noon base could be completed in a decade.
The first nation that establishes their space will be akin to the first nations
building outposts in the new world 500 years ago.
It's expensive to send rockets to the moon,
so we will send as little as possible.
The base will be light little more than inflatable habitats for crews of no more
than 12 and we'll be deployed somewhere with a natural shelter.
Options include caves like underground lava tube tunnels or craters near the
Poles where the days or six months long,
these astronauts will not stay long.
The habitat is likely to be abandoned between missions as solar panels cannot
generate electricity during the lunar night,
but they'll do the groundwork to enable humans to stay permanently.
Our first crew will consist of scientists and engineers who will study the
composition of the moon and who's experiments.
We'll explore ways of using the available Duna material,
say purifying the lunar ice and turning it into water for human use and water is
important for far more than drinking.
They can use it to experiment with growing plants for food.
Hydrogen fuel cells will store power through the long night.
Extending astronauts stays,
and most importantly,
it can be split into hydrogen and oxygen rocket fuel.
By harvesting water from the moon and putting it into orbit,
the moon base will supply an orbital depot where scientific missions to Mars and
the outer solar system can refuel.
Compared to the earth,
it's much easier and cheaper to get things off the mood into orbit.
Colonizing Mars may mean starting from the moon,
but this isn't a true colony.
No.
Yes,
the base will be abandoned.
Their funding stops.
If we want our base to grow into the third phase,
into a true colony,
it must become self sufficient supporting itself via exports to Earth.
Now,
private contractors arrive looking to get rich off lunar resources and support
services.
If it's cheaper to produce rocket fuel in space.
What else can they get rich on?
They could extract precious metals,
abundant in impact craters and other raw materials from the lunar regolith.
One promising possibility is the mining of helium three and isotope that could
one day be used in nuclear fusion reactors.
Something the Chinese lunar exploration program is currently looking into
future colonists may export helium three back to earth,
providing us with cheap and clean fusion energy.
Asteroids could be pulled into the moon's always and mind.
With commercial exports to Earth,
the colony is fully in it's third phase self sufficient and economically
productive.
Our base will begin using lunar material in its construction projects if it's to
continue growing.
Fortunately,
Luna Saul has all the necessary ingredients to make concrete robotic mining
rigs.
Consifted the lunar dust for organic molecules and could be used to build huge
structures,
way too massive to be brought from Earth.
While advances in three d printing will make it possible to produce almost
everything else the trues need.
It's hard to say when exactly the colony becomes self sustaining.
Growth is gradual.
Experiments are replaced by industry and the population steadily and which is
the hundreds encompassing more than just scientists,
engineers,
pilots,
and contractors' representing countries and corporations will be present
to have these people will make a breakthrough,
not scientific,
but social.
They will have the first extra terrestrial child.
Throughout history,
the birth of the first child was celebrated as a moment where the seed of a
colony finally and irreversibly to brute here,
it means that the moon is not just a place for scientists and engineers to work.
It's a place for people to live,
to raise a family.
Once this transition happens,
the colony grows rapidly building more habitats and schools and farms and all
the things needed to support the growing population.
As our colony grows,
all kinds of new technologies will be invented to sustain it.
They might develop crops that efficiently recycled carbon dioxide or that grow
with very little water.
They might find ways to recycle and reuse 100% of that waste technologies that
are extremely valuable for earth.
They could even build the first space innovator in the solar system with a space
elevator,
spacecraft,
astronauts,
and raw materials could be bought back and forth from Luna Orbis without needing
to use rockets at all.
The moon may become a hub for economic activity on a scale that's hard to
imagine right now.
It's hard to say who will own the colony at this point.
We'll the first person born on the moon,
take the national identity of their parents,
or will a new generation melt together into a new lunar society.
And when existing treaters,
the bar,
any nation from owning the moon are inevitably rewritten.
Will the colonists be given a saying,
will they declare independence from the earth?
However it happens,
the moon is a perfect sandbox to learn how to colonize the solar system,
the perfect project,
unify nations.
And the only way to guarantee our survival as a species should something tragic
happened on earth.
If we ever want to colonize the Milky Way,
we'll have to start somewhere.
So why not start there?
Why not start now?
Unfortunately,
you can jump on a spacecraft and goes to the boon of right now.
You can learn more interesting things about space and our universe and we can
even help you with that codes because Alta and brilliant are collaborating on a
six part video series about how favorite science and space topics quotes
[inaudible] has worked with brilliant for a while now,
and we love what they're doing in a nutshell.
Brilliant teaches you science and maths with a hands on approach by solving
puzzles yourself.
You lend to understand concepts instead of just memorizing facts.
If you'd like to think more like a scientist,
goto brilliant.org/nutshell and sign up for free,
the first 688 people to use the link at their annual premium membership at a 20%
discount and also support how collaboration with brilliant,
right?
Yeah.